alright so today I'm here to ask dance
the question can low-cost batteries help
us to use more renewables and build your
transmission lines the answer is yes and
the question so really that's that's an
obvious thing of course I'm going to say
yes right but thing we're really more
interested in is why is this a question
at all there's a couple of really simple
ways to explain this and it becomes more
complex but these two things for this
for this day is a reasonable way to
start first of all renewables are messy
they're very intermittent we want as
consumers a continuous source of power
that comes on whenever we need it and
goes off whenever we don't need it and
if you combine that with the idea that
electrons or electricity is about the
only commodity used it bulk massive
quantities that is not stored in some
way or other typically it means that we
have to have a sort of constant or
adjustable power supply it renewables
don't play like that they jump all over
the place this plot here on the right
shows a year's worth of wind data and
it's frayed jagged you see it this is
from a grated wind farm and it goes from
nearly zero on some days or hours all
the way up so you know some cases as
much as six single one so it's a huge
bit of variability so we want to be a
figure out how to harness this most
effectively and and certainly just
trying to use this as it's coming out on
such a jagged fashions not an
appropriate answer solar power is
similar it has very jagged daytime
depending on what kind of cloud cover we
have and what's going on and of course
it's dark at night and that darkness is
a real problem for that technology so no
matter how much solar we put up we get
nothing at nighttime so we need some way
to store the energy and then give it
back in times of other need the other
question is more about transmission
lines and the electricity grid is old
and as bottlenecks and needs to be
extended so this picture here on the
left is what most of us are presented
with when we think about a cartoon of
what the energy grid actually looks like
there's the generation station there's
some transmission villainy Google I
doubt there's substations distribution
stations to residential communities and
there's a line connecting them all right
very simple the reality is very
different this is a schematic of part of
the United States power grid and what
you see is that there's these
sort of clumps of use where you can
imagine a lot of cross sharing between
the different generation sources each
dot is a generation source for example
and these are the major transmission
lines but there are other places where
it's very tenuous you see here and down
here etc and you can imagine that if a
population shifts or something happens
someone builds a large factory somewhere
that strains this you want to transfer
energy from one resource to another
perhaps you can't at the right time of
day right if you had storage maybe you
could if you put it right next to one of
these major transmission lines if you
put a big battery say here for example
you can continually charge it during
off-peak hours and then when demand is
highest at that point you can pull from
the battery instead of the grid line
which means you don't have to build a
bigger line you can use some other asset
to give you the same outcome so that is
how badly would you that's why it's a
question right so what does the answer
look like what does the battery look
like that might do this we're already
using a lot of Pumped hydro in the world
this is where you pump a water up a hill
put in a reservoir during the at one
point and it comes down through a
turbine another point when you need it
very cheap very bulk storage but
unfortunately most of these locations
where this is applicable have been
implemented right and it's difficult to
build dams right now you often will
submerge valuable natural resources or
villages or towns or whatever so there
needs to be a more portable way of doing
this and to that end we get to you know
a couple options one is compressed gas
which you might do underground
subterranean compressed air also an
interesting option also site-specific in
fact recently there was a slight they
put in many 10 million many millions of
dollars to figure out even if it was a
legitimate site there's a lot of hope
didn't pan out so again very
site-specific so what I'm interested in
is what is portable we can put anywhere
we need that's very low cost that will
last a long time and so here's an
example to and this also this is a work
that a collaboration with Professor J
apt then this answers the age-old
question what do you do if you combine a
material scientist and retired astronaut
and let them do some work together you
end up answer the question about how
much wind you can put on with different
size batteries that when combined with
the fast ramping natural turbine the
answer is it really matters
if you have a hundred megawatt natural
and I'm not going to go through these
details at all because it's a it's a bit
complicated but to explain these these
two plots but the key thing I'll draw
your attention to is a point down here
the lowest point is the average cost of
power net present value in dollars per
megawatt hour that you can get if you
have 01 energy and just a gas turbine
it's yeah fifty-five sixty dollars per
megawatt hour oops and the other thing
is that if you put in the right size
battery and you want to get a lot of
energy from the wind instead of a
natural gas because of a variety of
incentives or just you want there's
reasons to do this for a lot of reasons
it turns out that you can get almost the
same price point if you have a
reasonably sized battery in this case of
21 megawatt-hour sodium salt for battery
and you can have up to thirty percent
wind penetration right so if thirty
percent you've now swapped out thirty
percent of the gas you were burning for
went free clean wind if you put a
battery in place and in the middle of
all of this right that's an exciting
answer so the question is well where
these batteries look like a lot of
constraints they got to be really cheap
they got to be cheaper than anything
we're making right now to adele's
kilowatt hour at capital cost so if i
put in a ten megawatt our system is
still going to cost a lot of money and
it has to last more than 10 years you
have to a more size net cost over a long
period of time and so to get to this
really low cost what's it look like what
does that be and what's a made of right
really abundant low cost materials with
simple manufacturing a simple balance of
system that is to say the stuff that
controls it also has to be really simple
inexpensive it's got to be very
environmentally adaptable and benign
edible or at least very easy to dispose
of not hazardous not flammable and a
very long lifetime again those people
those customers who are serious about
doing very large scale storage also take
the long view what if I what is this
last 20 years right what is the overall
value I get on a daily basis if this
operates for 20 years how do I make that
happen and it's got to be completely
reliable just as as though we rely on
the grid on a daily basis if the battery
fails something will go wrong it must
work and so this was the approach that I
took started CMU and there's been a
spin-off company
you just want one sentence on that in a
second you have a menu of viable
materials and these are these sort of
combinations of extremely common
low-cost things and then you have to go
through a series of steps with these
materials if you're going to work with
these and this is what really you have
to pick from if you're going to do this
because it's a vast questions or huge
kinds of things of objects and the only
way you can make this work is if you
have this kind of stuff that it has to
be not that pure because any of these if
they're too Peter also cost a lot of
money so it's a cost gate on that and
then you assess what you would do and
how you manufacture with the materials
and you have to do a cost gate on that
so if you think about how would I use
these and then you assess the
performance of how these might function
in a battery and the performance is
assessed against key things the
marketplace dollars per kilowatt hour is
it reliable is it safe right so all of
this comes together and resulted in
after a fair amount of poking and
prodding in my lab in 2007 and 2008 to a
really simple battery idea it's an Aquos
electrolyte sodium ion battery it's got
very little cost carbon as one electrode
and a manganese oxide material on the
other on the cathode side the plus side
that can accept and reject saudi mine so
when you charge the battery the sodium
goes in the carbon when you discharge it
goes back in the manganese oxide and
these things are very inexpensive and
the kicker is the electrolyte is sodium
sulfate and water so it's essentially a
saltwater this is a preservative where
we use in the food industry in the
separator itself is essentially very low
cost of synthetic cotton so everything
in this device is was incepted and put
together and designed to be cheap and
long lasting and it doesn't have rated
energy density could never be used in a
car it's not that good for a lot of like
mobile applications but if you want
something to sit there and last a long
time and just function this is maybe an
option right and so the innovation part
goes like this right you get something
really tiny in a lab that works you have
a lot of you know research group and you
get a little it's a look button cell
it's about this kind it goes in your
watch we can make these you test them
and it looks appealing and you say well
if I could make one trillion of these I
can change the world right of course you
can so you spend
16 months in a lab trying to understand
what it might look like to get bigger
and then you realize that you need more
help that you can't do it out of a
university that this is going to require
a bigger effort and mind you I can
certainly vouch you this firsthand you
don't do a manufacturing based energy
startup to become really rich right
that's that's for the web people right
this is this is a different thing
altogether the amount of capital it
requires to really do this is profoundly
large and the amount of time it takes is
very long and you've got to be willing
to go for the long haul and it may or
may not work right so work towards the
middle of our long haul and things are
looking good but this is not a get rich
fast scheme whatsoever um so in early
2010 we got some some substantial
venture venture interest and start a
spin-off here and down in lawrenceville
and our first sort of objects got a
little bigger about this big red box
size things and they're they're pretty
good pretty interesting and that
leveraged some more some more fun
explore interest and then we were sort
of building these objects now they're
about this tall about this big the
bottom just over a kilowatt hour of
capacity and they can be put together in
pallets and stacks and residences or in
buildings and so forth and we're
shipping this and we're doing all of
these things right now up until next
year here in lawrenceville and we're
opening a factory next year in
Westmoreland County we currently employ
just over a hundred people and by next
year we'll be over 200 people we've made
a lot of jobs that we've brought in a
fair amount of state money local money
federal money and venture cap to the
region and I think this is really having
an impact and it's kind of exciting to
have been a part of it and Carnegie
Mellon was extremely instrumental in
this and the interdisciplinary work here
has been fantastic and letting this
happen and i think the university as a
whole for all the support
so yeah I mean that's really good i mean
we're just finishing out one of our
tially projects we have demonstrated now
a over a thousand volt grid-tied unit
that is giving and taking from the grid
buying and selling as a huge proof of
concept and it gets us to grid scale
local grid scale voltages and shows good
performance and it just gives you an
idea we put those modules together in
pallets or containers or even much
larger arrays and we're now negotiating
with major customers who want many many
tens or hundreds of megawatt hours of
these to be put in and this is the scale
this is the inside of a factory right
now this was taken last week in
westmoreland you can see we're just
aren't you putting some walls we gutted
this this is the old sony plant it was a
lotta mode of a manufacturing plant
before that we're taking a fraction of
it right now we're about 30 and 50
thousand square feet but it's going to
grow next year this is going to be
populated with a lot of really
interesting equipment so stay tuned you
won't tell you how it goes thank
you